bonjour Le 7 8 l'actu bienvenue sur
téléfiles 78 l'essentiel de
l'information au local voici les titres
de ce vendredi 24 janvier 2014 la crise
du logement étudiant une réalité qui
pousse les pouvoirs publics à agir quel
est l'offre actuelle dans les Yvelines
et surtout et quelle solution se met en
place à l'association Icare qui fête ses
20 ans à l'université de Versailles 50
ans en Yvelines les étudiants se
relaient pour mener des actions
humanitaires retour sur deux décennies
de mobilisation de solidarité avec une
exposition nous en parlerons avec nos
invités et comme chaque vendredi
l'essentiel de la semaine retour sur la
mobilisation des policiers et sur la
disparition évoquée du département des
Yvelines nous parlerons aussi des
campagnes des municipales les examens
pas encore passé il faut pourtant se
préoccuper de son logement pour la
prochaine rentrée les inscriptions pour
les logements étudiants sont à remplir
jusqu'au 30 avril il faut faire preuve
de patience en Île-de-France la demande
est forte même si l'offre se renforce
encore un peu cette année Olivier
Maniscalco
mauvais élève en la matière la région
Île-de-France va renforcer son aide au
logement étudiant il faut dire qu'avec
aujourd'hui 5 logements disponibles pour
cet étudiant contre 8% au plan national
la situation francilienne a besoin d'un
fort rattrapage exemple du côté des
Yvelines ou certains jeunes rencontrent
des difficultés on a beaucoup
d'étudiants d'ailleurs qui n'hésitent
qui n'ont pas le choix que de faire deux
heures de transport pour venir étudier
chaque jour donc c'est évident que ça
diminue leur chance de réussite dans
leur parcours universitaire parce que le
temps qu'il mette dans le trajet
évidemment ils ne peuvent pas étudier
néanmoins la situation dans le 78 s'est
amélioré cette année le nombre de places
disponibles à même doublée avec
l'ouverture de 4 nouvelles résidences de
à Versailles intra-muros une à Viroflay
et une autre à Élancourt
800 places sont aujourd'hui disponibles
pour les étudiants un chiffre suffisant
selon le CROUS de Versailles pour cette
année grâce à cette à ses ouvertures
nous avons répondu à l'ensemble des
demandes qui nous étaient remontées de
la part des étudiants et à ce jour nous
n'avons plus d'étudiants sur liste
d'attentes depuis le 15 janvier les
inscriptions sont ouvertes sur le site
du CROUS de Versailles et ce jusqu'au 30
avril un mois d'attente sera nécessaire
pour savoir si vous pouvez bénéficier
d'une bourse et il vous faudra attendre
jusqu'à la mi-juin pour une réponse
concernant un logement l'an dernier plus
de 2000 demandes ont été adressées au
CROUS de Versailles
nous restons dans le domaine de
l'enseignement supérieur avec un focus
sur l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines dans la
tourmente depuis plusieurs mois en
raison d'un budget difficile à boucler
elle doit néanmoins continuer à séduire
les lycéens alors que s'ouvre également
les inscriptions pour la rentrée
prochaine le week-end dernier se
déroulait à Versailles au Palais des
Congrès le Salon de l'Étudiant nous
avons voulu savoir si l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
avait aujourd'hui mauvaise presse
reportage et il y a pas une inquiétude
généralisée on avait un peu contraigné
un peu malgré tout
officiellement pas de changement sur le
stand de l'UVSQ lors du Salon de
l'étudiant à Versailles on affirmé ne
pas avoir trop ressenti les inquiétudes
des lycéens le lourd difficile de
budgétaire et ses conséquences sur les
conditions d'enseignement ne
freineraient donc pas les inscriptions à
venir seulement en tendant un peu
l'oreille on se rend compte que l'on se
pose tout de même plus de questions que
les autres années je voulais y aller
sans poser de questions et maintenant
c'est vrai que je me pose un peu plus de
questions et je vais peut-être voir si
je peux pas aller dans une autre
université ou quelque chose comme ça
j'ai pas envie de commencer à faire mes
études à la fac de Versailles
Saint-Quentin pour ensuite devoir me
réorienter justement à cause de ces
problèmes là donc je suis venue chercher
des réponses pour poser des questions
aussi si justement c'est stable ou pas
l'université qui accuse plusieurs
millions de déficits à d'ores et déjà
annoncé devoir faire des économies en
supprimant notamment les filières les
moins fréquentées pour autant elle veut
défendre ses atouts
professionnalisante au niveau bac +2 par
les DUTS Bac +3 pour les licences
professionnelles on a 28 licences
professionnelles
et des masters professionnels en
quantité au total on a plus de 100
master dont une grande majorité de ma
soeurs professionnels avec beaucoup de
formations en apprentissage étape
déterminons d'après les traditionnelles
salons étudiants les journées porteuses
ouvertes dans les prochaines semaines
l'université on sera donc plus sur son
nombre d'inscriptions pendant qu'on
coulisse le bras de fer avec le
ministère se poursuit afin de décrocher
de plus fortes subventions
invité de ce journal elles sont deux
Tatiana tirloa bonsoir vous êtes
présidente de l'association
Icare et Marie cousin ancienne
présidente de cette même association
jusqu'en septembre 2003 donc c'est tout
récent bienvenue sur ce plateau vous
êtes réunis toutes les deux caricats
fête ses 20 ans on va repréciser ce
qu'est ICAR justement une association
qui intervient dans l'humanitaire qui
est géré par des étudiants de
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
Icare pour initiative de coopération
active par relais d'étudiants c'est bien
ça vous pouvez nous en dire plus qui
nous reprécise un peu le champ d'action
en fait qu'on développe des actions de
solidarité
humanitaire c'était beaucoup dans le
passé je pense que vous avez dû voir ça
dans l'exposition et je pense que Marie
pour en parler puisque elle a été à
l'initiative de l'exposition et on
développe aussi en fait des actions
environnementales qui est un gros pôle
chez nous et également en fait des
actions sociales donc ça veut dire qu'on
vingt ans l'émission de l'association
est un peu évolué en fait en fonction
des étudiants qui sont impliqués en fait
c'est ça ça dépend des engagements des
envies des motivations et c'est des
projets en fait qui se suivent parfois
d’année en année et pas toujours avec en
fait les mêmes membres c'est une volonté
parfois de la part de certains de
vouloir reproduire et parfois d'avoir
innover aussi
Icare 20 ans d'existence c'est long pour
une association étudiante et plus forte
raison à Versailles 50 ans en Yvelines
parce que ça correspond quasiment avec
la naissance de l'université donc
comment on peut expliquer une si longue
vie à écart ça a été donc créé un an
après l'université c'était une volonté
avant tout des associations qui étaient
en filière économique qui voyait le
développement de l'Europe se faire et
c'est pour ça que les premiers projets
ont été d'abord humanitaires et cibler
sur les pays d'Europe de l'Est et puis
petit à petit bah ça a changé les
mentalités ont changé les envies et les
engagements des étudiants ont changé et
on est parti sur des projets d'abord
sociaux de la prévention santé parce que
c'est important d'en parler au sein
d'une université des de l'accompagnement
auprès de SDF d'école du soutien
scolaire et petit à petit avec
l'université aussi de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui se
développait des préoccupations liées au
développement durable et donc du coup un
pôle environnemental et de solidarité
qui s'est développée par la suite et on
retrouve tout ça à travers l'exposition
qui est actuellement proposée à la
bibliothèque universitaire c'est
boulevard Vauban à Guyancourt on en a vu
quelques images quels sont les moments
forts qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve à travers
cette exposition c'est vous qui avez
travaillé dessus notamment exactement ça
me tenait à coeur puisque j'ai travaillé
dessus pendant près de six mois le temps
de parcourir 20 années d'archives 20
génération d'étudiants qui se sont
mobilisés et donc tout au long de
l'exposition on retrouve à la fois cette
évolution de projet donc l'humanitaire
le social puis ensuite l'environnement
et maintenant des projets de solidarité
autant tourner vers l'international que
vers le local puisqu'on essaye d'avoir
un ancrage territorial assez important
avec d'autres structures d'autres
partenaires et d'autres associations de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et également
expliquer aux étudiants que s'engager
dans une associations c'est valorisable
pour la suite et donc du coup qui a un
travail aussi administratif au sein
d'une association et qu'on peut
valoriser nos compétences sur des
événements phares qui sont à la fois sur
le campus et à la fois sur la communauté
d'agglomérations
exactement puisque au fur et à mesure
mes compestants ont amplifié et je suis
fortement intéressée par le secteur
associatif maintenant et d'un point de
vue professionnel et je viens tout juste
de signer un contrat de service civique
dans une ressourcerie donc tout ce qui
est réemploi réduction des déchets et
j'ai envie de vraiment me
professionnaliser et continuer dans ce
secteur là et je pense que ça a été la
volonté aussi de goûts beaucoup beaucoup
de personnes qui se sont engagées il y
en a notamment maintenant qui ont créé
leur propre association qui emploi dans
leur propre association donc voilà ça
continue
qui est toujours engagé dans ce domaine
il est venu parler des AMAPs il y a très
longtemps c'est c'est jardin c'est
filières courtes auxquelles vous
participez aussi on va les évoquer tout
à l'heure d'ailleurs ses AMAP qu'est-ce
qu'il y a motivé votre participation à
écart parce que vous concerne
effectivement en rencontrant directement
des membres que j'ai compris qu'il y
avait la possibilité de d'agir en fait
de façon citoyenne et pour animer aussi
bien le campus c'est vrai que c'est
souvent un intérêt personnel et c'est
aussi parce que face à l'avenir on a
envie de se forger et c'est une
expérience qui est vraiment géniale je
la conseille à tout le monde en fait
votre meilleur souvenir de cet
engagement de passer très rapidement de
charger de communication où il y a pas
beaucoup de tâches à présidente et avoir
beaucoup de responsabilités diriger une
équipe ce qui est effectivement comme
l'a dit Tatiana forge et permet à la
suite de faire ses preuves donc c'est
vrai que c'est des moments où on a tout
de suite beaucoup de responsabilités ou
des événements phares aussi qu'on a créé
la map de la cagette verte effectivement
qui est le projet phare du moment
peut-être s'y attardé on parle du
utiliser les 20 ans mais il y a toujours
des nouveaux projets et des projets qui
sont menés encore actuellement alors
cette AMAP cette Association pour le
Maintien d'une Agriculture Paysanne
consiste en quoi sur l'université
verte donc permet en fait aussi bien à
des étudiants mais on venait aussi
tourner vers l'extérieur puisque
d'aiguilles en courtois ou des personnes
en fait qui travaillent dans
l'université peuvent bénéficier de cette
de cette AMAP et participer puisque
c'est aussi participatif l'idée c'est de
soutenir des producteurs locaux donc on
s'est tourné vers la vallée de Chevreuse
et on a la possibilité de d'avoir
aujourd'hui un panier de légumes des
œufs du pain qui sont des produits donc
de la région on a des produits de saison
et on participe aussi à un soutien
directement sur place à la possibilité
de faire des visites aux fermes
pédagogiques et voilà aujourd'hui on est
on est contents puisque pour la
troisième saison on a un avantage porté
aux étudiants grâce à à tout le monde
subventions qui ont été à donner par
l'université et qui permet justement de
sensibiliser des étudiants qui n'ont pas
toujours les moyens de
de se tourner vers des alternatives en
termes alimentaires et sur ce qu'on
pense souvent pour les étudiants
concernent des produits naturels qui
sont souvent un peu plus cher donc
aujourd'hui en fait on a la possibilité
de d'offrir un avantage financier à ces
étudiants pour pouvoir en bénéficier et
participer à des actions qu'on anime
autour de ce sujet et voilà si vous
voulez en savoir plus sur écart je vous
le rappelle cette exposition qui se
déroule actuellement en bibliothèque
universitaire à Guyancourt il y aura
d'autres actions pour remarquer les 20
ans parce que d'autres choses sont
prévues alors on a lancé les incroyables
comestibles en fait au balcon du local
associatif ou alors c'est incroyable
comestibles donc c'est un mouvement qui
a été lancé alternatif pour partager en
fait de la nourriture à son échelle
enfin propre aussi bien en fait au
balcon de sa fenêtre mais ça peut être
aussi des bacs qu'on en ce moment dans
les communes arrivées en pleine rue ou
ben des personnes bénévoles viennent
planter des plantes et enfin donc des
comestibles et on peut se servir
gratuitement et donc nous on en a un sur
notre local associatif on a mis des
fraisiers voilà qui en était donnent
généreusement pour les passants regardez
un œil sur ce qui se passe à écart
totalement aujourd'hui en plus la
construction d'Icare faisant que on est
à 20 ans maintenant bientôt 21 ans il y
a tout un groupe de personnes derrière
il y a une vraie famille qui essaie de
poursuivre les projets on a parfois des
anciens étudiants qui travaillent
maintenant qui sont pas forcément dans
la région qui viennent animer des
projets on avait par exemple l'année
dernière
Ellis fauché qui travaille la
médiathèque qui est venu pour animer des
journées sur sur l'autisme pendant la
semaine en diifac de l'université
c'était porté par Ricard donc très
souvent on a un appui des entiers voilà
c'est ça 40 ans merci à toutes les deux
d'être passé sur ce plateau cette
exposition à découvrir donc à Guyancourt
et puis un site internet pour en savoir
aussi un peu plus merci à toutes les
deux d'être venu donc on quitte
l'enseignement supérieur pour le
primaire les rythmes scolaires qui vont
changer des cette rentrée peut-être
avez-vous d'ailleurs participé à des
ateliers dans votre commune pour mettre
en place dans de meilleures conditions
possibles cette réforme nous avons voulu
savoir si toutes les communes dans les
Yvelines étaient prêtes les cours
vont-ils se dérouler le mercredi ou le
samedi et surtout quels seront les
activités qui seront proposées aux
enfants sur les nouveaux temps libres à
venir c'est un dossier de Yolaine Torres
les rythmes scolaires c'est pour
septembre et le mercredi semble pour le
moment l'emporter sur le samedi à
Bois-d'Arcy Maurepas Voisins le
bretonneux Montigny-le-Bretonneux ou
encore Guy en cours le temps
d'enseignement supplémentaire sera
instauré le mercredi matin de 8h30 à
11h30 un choix validé suite aux
concertations menée auprès des parents
d'élèves et des partenaires du monde
éducatif local ce passage à la semaine
de quatre jours et demi doit alléger le
rythme de travail quotidien des enfants
en semaine ils auront donc trois heures
de temps libre en plus du temps qui sera
alors réservé aux nouveaux temps
d'activités périscolaires certaines
communes du département sont en train
d'affiner le contenu de ces nouveaux
temps libres
avoisin-le-bretonneux 8m ont déjà été
retenus
il y en a 8 qui sont autour bien sûr de
l'expression corporelle l'expression
artistique mais aussi la citoyenneté la
santé aussi ça nous a semblés être un
thème important en ce moment l'éducation
à la santé à l'alimentation autre
conséquence de cette réforme pour les
municipalités l'organisation des locaux
avoisins-le-bretonneux toujours on a
fait le choix d'ouvrir tous les groupes
scolaires de la ville le mercredi
après-midi aujourd'hui nous avons deux
groupes scolaires ouverts le mercredi
pour les six groupes scolaires de
voisins et bien là nous avons pris une
décision importante mais qui nous
semblait nécessaire pour maintenir au
maximum les repères aux enfants nous
allons ouvrir les
centre de loisirs dans les six groupes
scolaires le mercredi autre ville
Guyancourt ici les discussions se
poursuivent appartient la semaine
prochaine les équipes de la ville vont
aller rencontrer des équipes
enseignantes puisque il faut aussi qu'on
voit l'aménagement des salles que nous
on va utiliser alors donc on va
travailler groupe scolaire par groupe
scolaire parce que les problématiques
sont différentes d'une école à une autre
dans certaines écoles on a des centres
de loisirs d'autres on n'a pas donc il
faut effectivement qu'on voit
l'organisation des sacs quel sera le
coût de ces changements à Guyancourt on
évoque pour le moment un montant de
300.000 euros tandis qu'un voisin le
Bretonneux on prévoit 240000 euros de
dépenses sur les prochains budgets soit
200 à 300 euros par enfant et par an le
recrutement d'animateurs supplémentaires
est aussi à prendre en compte dans leur
budget
à noter que pour la première année
d'application de la réforme l'État met à
disposition des communes 50 euros par
élève et 90 euros dans les zones en
difficulté si ajoute une prestation
versée par les Caisses d'Allocations
Familiales de 53 euros par an et par
enfant quoi qu'il en soit l'inspection
académique devra récupérer l'ensemble
des projets avant la fin du mois de juin
même si à Élancourt on refuse toujours
de s'y soumettre le maire souhaite
quelque chose de plus consensuel on a
fait nos trois concertations une avec
les profs une avec les parents d'élèves
et une avec nos animateurs bon dans les
trois cas on a bien senti clairement que
il y avait plutôt un avis négatif qui se
dégageait je veux pas m'opposer pour
m'opposer simplement voilà il faut qu'on
prouve comme Monsieur Peillon sera
capable de m'expliquer que ça améliore
les rythmes scolaires et que c'est et
qui me dira qui finance exactement
comment financer qui finance d'abord
combien ça coûte il ne sait même pas
combien ça coûte qui finance et surtout
quelle est la valeur ajoutée pour les
enfants moi c'est ça qui est déterminé
dans le département des Yvelines 9
communes dont celle de Trappes applique
déjà la semaine de 4 jours et demi
depuis 2013
pourquoi ne pas fusionner Yvelines et
haute scène le gouvernement a ouvert la
discussion autour de la suppression des
départements et depuis les déclarations
se multiplient enfin de semaine dernière
c'est le président du conseil général
des Hauts-de-Seine Patrick devejan qui
annonçait ne pas avoir attendu les
déclarations du président François
Hollande pour rapprocher pour se
rapprocher de son homologue UMP
yvelinois Alain Schmitt une nouvelle
collectivité qui regrouperait 3 millions
d'habitants les deux élus évoquent des
réductions de dépenses publiques des
projets d'envergure également plus
facile à mener et vous que pensez-vous
de cette idée de réunion de scène et
Evelyne micro-trottoir
sur le principe de simplifier un peu le
mille-feuille administratif oui ça me
paraît
utile après sur le cas précis des
Yvelines et des Hauts-de-Seine j'avoue
que je ne connais pas suffisamment le
dossier pour me prononcer avec les
Hauts-de-Seine je sais pas je suis
sceptique moi je suis pour c'est comme
tout le monde le millefeuille
administratif où il y a les les communes
les communautés d'agglomération les
départements les régions l'état puis
même l'Europe finalement donc il
faudrait arriver sur ces 5 niveaux à en
garder trois ça suffirait bien bah
écoutez comme ces deux départements qui
sont assez riches donc je pense que bon
ça peut valoriser je pense que c'est ça
c'est une taille intermédiaire en train
département une c'est pratiquement une
région à elle seule une petite région
mais
quand tu vas moi aussi bien géré moi
l'autre côté
voilà
le syndicat de police à Lyon se mobilise
à nouveau les agents 6000 policiers ce
sont retrouvés le 13 novembre dernier
déjà devant l'Assemblée nationale pour
dénoncer conditions de vie et de travail
devant l'absence de changement des
actions étaient menées mercredi dernier
devant toutes les directions
départementales de la sécurité publique
ici à Viroflay ou encore à Évry Cergy
Melun étaient évoqué harcèlement moral
stigmatisation pression sur les
objectifs ou encore manque de moyens
dans la ligne de mire du syndicat
méthode managérial conditions de travail
et restrictions budgétaire une
manifestation nationale et unitaire pour
être aussi rapidement être organisé
vous avez souvent des des patrouilles
qui sont amenés à patrouiller avec un
adjoint de sécurité et intitulée donc un
manque de sécurité certaines vous avez
des patrouilles qui sont obligés de se
transporter sur d'autres communes parce
que manque de d'effectif sur les autres
circonscriptions de police donc c'est
vrai que c'est un vrai casse-tête au
quotidien pour assurer correctement la
sécurité de nos concitoyens sur ce
département avec le manque d'effectif
que l'on a sur dans la police nationale
beaucoup de collègues sont rappelés sur
leurs jours de repos ne peuvent pas
avoir leur jour de congé comme il se
doit et donc viennent travailler sur
leurs jours de repos la réalité c'est
qu'il faudrait débloquer les moyens
faire en sorte que la modernisation de
l'action publique qui bloque aujourd'hui
le nombre de gens qui rentrent en école
de police soit clairement ouvert et que
en fait il y a davantage de recrutement
et surtout des budgets adéquats pour
pouvoir entretenir le parc automobile
mais aussi les moyens qui sont utilisés
tous les jours les moyens individuels et
collectifs il y a dans les années 2000
juste pour vous donner un ordre d'idée
8000 fonctionnaires de police qui
étaient formés dans les écoles de police
aujourd'hui on peine à remplir les
écoles de police à hauteur de 2500
et cette nouvelle manifestation
intervient alors que les chiffres de la
délinquance sont en hausse en France et
dans les Yvelines avec notamment une
hausse des cambriolages politiques la
semaine dernière sur notre antenne le
maire de Saint-Cyr-l'École Bernard
demain exprimait son souhait de voir
revenir travailler avec lui son ancienne
adjointe aujourd'hui candidate c'est pas
un communiqué que cette dernière vient
de lui répondre Gaëtane Desjardins
répond à Bernard Debin qu'il n'y aura
aucune discussion avant le premier tour
sa liste se veut indépendante de celle
menée par l'UMP et surtout elle refuse
d'assumer le bilan du maire candidat
qu'elle qualifie de mauvais en précisant
échec de grands projets et manque
d'éthique notamment toujours concernant
les municipales UMP et udi ont finalisé
leur soutien pour les municipales dans
les Yvelines pas de surprises si ce
n'est à Coignières ou le maire sortant
Henri Payet devrait se présenter en tant
que divers droites il s'expliquera
d'ailleurs mercredi dans le journal sur
ce plateau des 18 heures et puis à
Maurepas si les candidats des deux
formations ne fusionnent pas leur liste
les investitures seraient tout
simplement retirer les précisions et les
réactions des principaux concernés
à Maurepas l'UMP et l'UDI donneront une
investiture commune et une liste
d'unions le Guérinel garestiés en
l'absence d'une telle liste d'union UMP
et udon décidé de retirer les deux
investitures données sur cette ville le
communiqué est signé de la fédération
départementale de l'UMP depuis plusieurs
mois les deux hommes s'opposent sur la
ville d'un côté Pierre Le Guérinel
ancien premier adjoint du maire sortant
Georges Mougeot vice-président de l'UDI
dans les Yvelines et qui se présente
avec sur sa liste Nicole Malaquin
ancienne candidat tu MP en 2008 de
l'autre Grégory garestier responsable
local de l'UMP qui revendique 5
adhérents de l'UDI sur sa liste deux
hommes impossibles à mettre d'accord
donc et malgré la pression aujourd'hui
exercé par leur formation les choses ne
devraient pas changer
avec moi et je lui ai demandé de
réfléchir à la délégation qu'il
souhaitait avoir
sont acquérir une expérience
qu'aujourd'hui il n'a pas mais ce que
lui dit d'ailleurs le
MP j'ai entendu devant moi dire que il
n'avait pas l'expérience nécessaire le
seul souci c'est de conservion il faut
pouvoir discuter et si vous êtes face à
quelqu'un qui de toute façon ne
je suis persuadé que je serai en tête au
premier tour et je pense que Monsieur le
Garnier
donc il est fait
de
sorte d'intéresse pas je trace ma route
mon équipe allait complète ma liste
allait fait et donc je ne vois pas
pourquoi je ferai une alliance avec
celui qui a été le premier adjoint dans
maire de gauche et une majorité
socialiste pendant 6 ans et qui a fait
perdre la droite en 2008 bien le
Guérinel qui précise qu'il y a aucun
moment l'udaïne envisagerait de lui
retirer son investiture même s'il devait
se présenter seul le discours est moins
affirmatif pour Grégory garestier on en
est pas là nous verrons les choses dans
les semaines qui viennent mais en tout
cas moi ma position allait claire et
nous verrons ce qu'il adviendrons mais
en tout cas je reste le responsable UMP
de la ville de Maurepas prochaine étape
du bras de fer ce week-end avec un point
presse comme un très attendu de Valérie
Pécresse et d'Arnaud Richard les deux
présidents dont les Yvelines de l'UMP et
de l'UDA
élection municipale 23 et 30 mars pour
les communes de plus de 1000 habitants
des nouveautés les électeurs voteront à
la fois pour les conseils municipaux
mais aussi pour les conseils
communautaires
voilà à quoi ressemblera demain votre
bulletin de vote lors des prochaines
élections dont le premier tour a lieu le
23 mars à gauche les listes des
candidats au Conseil municipal à droite
la liste des candidats au Conseil
communautaires car nouveauté du code
électoral les électeurs des communes de
plus de 1000 habitants voteront aussi
pour les délégués qui siègeront au
Conseil Communautaire tous les
conseillers communautaires doivent
apparaissent sur la liste municipale et
dans un dans un ordre bien précis je
rappelle que
l'écossible municipaux sont paritaire
c'est-à-dire que il doit y avoir un
homme une femme un homme une femme et ce
sera la même chose pour les conseillers
communautaires en homme une femme comme
une femme et généralement ce sont les
têtes dans les tests de la liste comme
municipale qu'ils doivent se retrouver
dans liste communautaire vous ne pourrez
pas rayer de nom ou en rajouter les
électeurs pourront se présenter pour
voter sans carte d'électeurs mais
obligatoirement avec une pièce
d'identité que sont une carte d'identité
ou un passeport
on peut présenter un titre d'identité
carte nationale d'identité passeport on
peut aussi également d'autres présenter
d'autres types de documents qui ne sont
pas des petites identité mais qui
prouvent quand même son nom on peut par
exemple présenter une carte Vitale avec
photographie et seulement avec
photographie quand on candidat ils
devront tous se déclarer en préfecture
et en sous-préfecture c'est une
nouveauté ils pourront prendre
rendez-vous dès le 3 février ils devront
présenter des bulletins de vote au
format paysage avec des côtes très
précises un bulletin non valide sera
refusé le dépôt des candidatures s'ouvre
du 13 février au 6 mars 3 semaines au
lieu d'une en raison des modifications
du code électoral un renfort d'agent
administratif et prévu des sites
Internet sont à la disposition de ceux
qui veulent en savoir plus
on se retrouve lundi pour une nouvelle
semaine d'information excellent weekend
sur notre antenne